à paris deux manifestations soutien au
peuple palestinien sont organisées ce
week-end cette fois autorisée elles
devront toutefois rester statique après
décision du préfet à l'appel de
l'association france palestine
solidarité le rassemblement de cet après
midi est prévu à 15 heures place de la
république la semaine dernière malgré
l'interdiction pour des risques de
troubles la manifestation avait
rassemblé entre 3000 et 5000 personnes
apparition en direct avec nous pour en
parler taoufik thani président d'honneur
de l'association france palestine
solidarité
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rtl france alors on va tout d'abord
parler des aspects techniques de cette
ce rassemblement rassemblement autorisé
mais statique
est-ce que cela vous satisfait bah
écoute et non ça ne satisfait pas dans
toutes les capitales européennes et dans
le monde entier
je dirais même dans certaines villes
israéliennes également des
manifestations solidarité avec la
palestine sont autorisés mais pas ici à
paris c'est une honte pour la france
la france qui est le pays de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme
n'autorise pas de la solidarité avec
avec la palestine et ils se cachent
derrière des mensonges honteux parce
qu'il faut ils disent que ça peut
provoquer des violences ou bien il ya
d'écrit antisémites et tous etc
nous avons lancé un défi de montrer une
seule fois où il y avait des cris
antisémites dans les manifestations 2014
alors qu'il y avait de l'avenir du
ministre de l'intérieur de l'époque 500
4 485 manifestation autorisée par les
différentes préfectures
il y avait cinq qui était qui était un
petit peu perturbé par ce qu'elle était
elle était interdite
c'est honteux ici en france parce que il
y a une politique délibérée de la part
d'un certain nombre de deux
personnalités qui maintenant elles sont
vraiment dans le compte de l'extrême
droite même si elle comme manuel valls
qui est un peu un millier socialiste
mais il est maintenant vraiment le
porte-parole de l'extrême droite
israélien et qui tente parce qu'ils sont
affolés de l'ampleur de la solidarité
avec la cause palestinienne qui les
solidaires ils savent très bien que
c'est quelque chose de politique nous
n'avons strictement rien d'antisémite
si on passe à côté d'une du sinagot ou
d'un lieu de culte juif bain cet endroit
il va être le plus
sûr au monde parce que nous trompons pas
d'ennemi nous savons que l'ennemi celle
à l'extrême droite israélien qui
massacrent ne peut pas laisser donc vous
avez ce vase et puis d'autres
intellectuels dans ces responsables
politiques ou responsables politiques
même maintenant qu'ils essaient de
délégitimer de la solidarité avec la
palestine en l'assimilant à
l'antisémitisme ou en l'assimilant à la
violence qui est absolument faux une
savent que c'est faux et d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que nous continuons le
combat pour leur démontrer non seulement
que c'est faux mais que nous allons
continuer la solidarité avec le peuple
palestinien
nous savons pertinemment que la question
n'est pas une question religieuse comme
usé ce2 là de faire de faire de faire
croire la question des crises en
question politique c'est une question de
l'occupation de colonisation et
d'apartheid
donc maintenant nous sommes très
contents et d'ailleurs nous allons
aujourd'hui affirmer notre solidarité
nous avons également célébrés ce cessez
le feu
parce que oui il faut mettre fin à cette
ces bombardements inhumains qui ont
détruit une partie de gaza et puis tu es
beaucoup de gens mais nous allons
également faire passer un message clair
au gouvernement français le mouvement
celui d'un état qui va s'amplifier
moment solidarité il est juste le
mouvement solidarité il est l'honneur de
la france
la réaction voire politique maintenant
ou bien d'un certain nombre de que que
j'appelle kahaniste en référence avec sa
droite israélienne ne nous font pas
intimider parce que c'est un combat
qu'il faut mener alors vous parlez des
10 du cessez le feu
vous parliez du cessez le feu il ya une
trêve certes dont se félicite en
ailleurs la communauté internationale
pour autant le conflit dans la région
est très loin d'être réglée bien sûr ce
que j'allais dire c'est que il ya celle
fait c'est déjà pas mal mais il faut
maintenant le sait c'est de la pâte est
cc repartaient cesser les sources du
groupe les sources de ce prologue il ya
une occupation il faut que ça cesse les
colonisations il faut que l cesse la
pâte elle qui est maintenant pointé par
toutes les ong les organisations non
gouvernementales internationales
israéliens palestiniens qui se respecte
et qui décrit une situation d'apartheid
dans toute la palestine historique pas
uniquement à gaza et en cisjordanie ou à
jérusalem est mais également chez les
palestiniens d'israël qui sont victimes
de cette politique d'apartheid
vous savez ce que ce qui est ce qui est
étonnant c'est que l'on continue
d'assurer une impunité au gouvernement
israélien
alors qu'il attend des lois que aucun
autre gouvernement y compris ceux de
l'extrême droite lessive en europe
quelques tels que en autriche ou en
hongrie knows no faire quand on a un
gouvernement israélien qui autorise qui
évoque une loi en 2018
il s'appelle la loi est un accent du
peuple juif ou le considère que tous
tous ceux qui ne sont pas juives ils
sont une part le droit termine à sion
c'est de la pâte est très simple ça se
fait plus entendre ce siècle 21e siècle
donc la communauté internationale si
elle veut vraiment être sérieusement sa
condamnation donc plutôt sa recherche
d'une paix juste et durable il faut
qu'elle commence déjà par participé au
démantèlement de cet apartheid nous de
toute façon on y va on continuera ce
mais ne voulons que les zetas et s'ils
mettent également et il doit refaire
exactement ce qu'ils avaient fait face
au régime d'apartheid d'afrique du sud
le démantèlement de l'apartheid il teste
à des sanctions il faut des sanctions
contre le gouvernement criminel d'israël
alors voilà vous parliez d'impunité pour
l'état israélien qui selon vous assure
cette impunité
j'allais dire que pratiquement tous les
états membres monde ça influents ont par
exemple les états unis ou bien même la
plupart des pays européens
ir il ya par exemple
la cour pénale internationale qui
souhaite maintenant faire des
investigations sur les crimes israéliens
qui est en crise qui s'est ajoutée à ce
dossier les etats unis font tout pour
empêcher la cour pénale internationale
d'enquêter
il ya des pays comme l'allemagne et tout
etc qui sont ouvertement contre ses
investigations
mais alors qui font certainement des
pressions en catimini ou bien au moins
il n'encourage pas la cour pénale
internationale dans ses enquêtes la
france par exemple ben qu'elle n'a
jamais dit bon bien sûr qu'il ne faut
pas enquêter sur ces crimes israéliens
mais n'a jamais salué la décision de la
cour pénale internationale de d'enquêter
sur ces crimes
donc ça veut dire que de toute façon
cette communauté internationale ces
décideurs et ou externe
il assure l'impunité d'israël quand on
voit les premières prises de positions
concrètes du gouvernement français de
tous les pays européens de lyon perd des
états unis
c'est la condamnation de roquettes du
hamas
mais ne nous ont jamais parlé de deux de
toutes les instructions qui sont faites
par l'armée israélienne qui dispose d'un
arsenal impressionnant qui a fait des
dégâts que les gazaouis que nous avons
eus au téléphone nous disent que les
guerres de 2014 et 2012 et 2008 2009
était terrible mais les destructions de
cette phase iib sont sans commune mesure
il ya des arbres qui ont été utilisés
qui sont beaucoup plus puissantes que
celles utilisées ailleurs et tout ceci
dans un territoire petit avec deux
millions de personnes qui sont entassés
qui ont déjà connu l'exil plusieurs fois
depuis 1948 ils n'ont jamais qu'on est
vraiment une p oui la communauté
internationale elle et tentent d'assurer
l'impunité à israël mais bon de l'autre
côté vous savez tout ce que compte le
monde d'organisations internationales
sérieuses de l'association de solidarité
qui sont très nombreux
par le monde ils sont du côté du plus
faible du côté du palestinien du côté de
celui qui subit cette politique
d'apartheid d'occupation de colonisation
je suis désolé on est pressé par le
temps merci en tout cas vous d'avoir
répondu à nos questions d'être président
d'honneur de l'association france
palestine solidarité qui appellent à une
manifestation cet après midi moi je suis
un vrai test
merci